in our series three meals we travel to
different states to break bread with
voters and hear what's on their minds
this morning two weeks before election
day we visit the Battleground state of
Pennsylvania the only debate between
Democratic Senate candidate John
Federman and Republican nominee amid Oz
will take place tonight the CBS News
Battleground tracker shows fetterman
with a small lead of just two points
meaning the race is still a toss-up our
national correspondent jurika Duncan
spoke with the voters in three
Pennsylvania counties and got a taste of
issues they're focused on
Pennsylvania the Keystone State is vast
in its beauty and instrumental as a
Battleground for the highly contested
Statewide elections so our first stop is
Lucerne Pennsylvania now this is an
interesting place because it neighbors
Scranton Pennsylvania which is where
President Biden grew up historically
it's been a blue County until Trump
flipped it red back in 2016. at Chuck's
Main Street Diner a bustling breakfast
spot in the heart of town hello there
how are you all this morning good how
are you we met friends Tony zambito and
Jim Reno who come here just about every
morning how are you guys feeling about
some of the issues and the candidates
well I think the Republicans are are
going to do really well this time around
because deflation
open borders
gas prices yeah everything's not good
I'm looking for a candidate that's going
to stimulate the economy get it moving
give give my children my grandchildren
opportunities to survive and get the
things that we did over the last 20
years I would say that I have voted both
ways Democrat and Republican I vote for
the candidates I don't vote for a party
Mike Bayer says he's most concerned
about the polarization and hostility
dominating the political climate it
seems like everyone's got a side with
one side and everyone's going to side
with the other side
and everything you hear is constant
fighting between the lines so while
everyone's bidding fighting politicians
are running to the bank with our money
Jeanette and John Stevenson have lived
in Lucerne for 40 years where do you
feel like our country is headed if
people would get Biden a chance I mean I
what's happening now I don't think would
just be because of Biden who ever got in
it's just the way things are
next we're headed south to Northampton
County now this is known as a political
Bellwether a long time purple swing
County that Trump narrowly won by 0.7
percent back in 2020. Main Street
restaurant a local lunch favorite boasts
the best cheesesteaks in town I don't
necessarily always vote my party I feel
as if I want to vote for the best person
for the job but I don't know who that is
is that frustrating it is very Maria and
Vernon's grandson Jackson just turned
18. and he decided not to register to
vote you just see the commercials on TV
and everything and they're just they're
all coming at each other and arguing
about everything and uh I just don't
feel like
that's something to stress about yet
Pennsylvania is one of eight states with
an open seat for governor and with a lot
at stake both President Biden and former
president Trump have visited the state
several times in recent months there's a
lot of issues what's most pressing for
you and your family I have two girls so
the issue with Roe versus Wade is a big
issue for me and if things don't change
it could only go worse further for the
girls or for the women in the future
Kathy and her 26 year old son Joe both
say they worry about the future of the
country and their right to vote
regardless of what your opinion is who
you
report whatnot every American has the
right to vote people tried to take that
from us because they didn't like what
the majority of us said when you say
people trying to take that from us are
you referring to the January 6th yes
January 6th they live in a democracy
that has its choice
[Music]
our last stop brings us to the
birthplace of democracy Philadelphia
where issues like gun violence and crime
are on the minds of many voters here in
fact Pennsylvania as a whole reported a
greater year-over-year increase in
violence than any other state in the
country
Positano Coast is a popular restaurant
among locals in Old cities
everyone we spoke with here says the
uptick in crime is a problem I have a
daughter who is nine years old
the alarming rate in you know an
increase in school shootings really
concerned me a lot it's just the babies
are running around hurting each other
and they don't realize they're part of a
larger Community a larger cause and it's
as if they don't value him in life
anymore they don't value their own lives
they don't see a future for themselves
or their communities or their friends
when you look at the
candidates and your options are you
pleased with what these politicians are
offering you you know I mean I I am
going to choose to vote for John
betterman but I uh I'd like to have
other options despite that 24 year old
Greg Gaiman says this is a time where
it's more important than ever to vote I
mean a lot of people say your vote
doesn't count and there's reasons behind
that but it definitely does I mean it's
the only way to make your voice heard
realistically as an individual in this
country
and that is something we keep hearing
time and time again you know I did a
three Meal special a few years ago in
Nevada and it is this idea that we've
become so divided that those who are
engaged in our political system feel
like this is the time to make your voice
heard
um but economy crime abortion rights
those were all sort of topics that we
kept hearing you had people who didn't
want to go on camera just because of the
sensitivity of some of the things that
we're talking about being judged and how
they feel but I'm always struck at once
people get going and they feel
comfortable really expressing how they
feel they have a lot to say they have a
lot to say they really do well done
jarika thank you so much